this government's failure to grow the
economy over a decade
combined with its inertia in the face of
spiraling bills
means that we are staring down the
barrel of something we haven't seen in
decades
a stagflation crisis
it is a truly shocking legacy of this
government
it should humble those on the benches
opposite who've ignored the red lights
on our economy even whilst wages were
frozen for over a decade
and whose complacency is best summed up
by a prime minister whose response to
the crisis
was to make fun of those that were
worrying about inflation
a government of the moment would use the
great powers that it has to tackle this
head-on
bring forward an emergency budget
with a windfall tax a windfall tax for
oil and gas producers which would raise
billions
the money that could be used to slash
the cost of energy bills and help
businesses keep their costs down
even the bosses at bp don't agree
when the prime minister says it would
deter investment
it's a common sense solution
but instead
the government is bereft of leadership
the chancellor ruling the windfall tax
in
the business secretary ruling it out
and a prime minister who doesn't know
what he thinks
and it's not just about the short-term
measures a government of the moment
will take a step back from the crisis
and ensure that britain is never again
so vulnerable to a surge in
international prices forced to go cap in
hand from dictator to dictator looking
for a quick fix of imported oil
that means standing up to those vested
interests who oppose onshore wind the
cheapest and most reliable source of
electricity that we have
but this prime minister is too weak to
stand up to his back benches
and it means investing in the insulation
we need to use less energy in our homes
that would take 400 pounds off energy
bills every year
and cut gas imports by 15
but this prime minister is far too
concerned with vanity projects ever to
prioritize investment in insulating
homes
so we're left with an energy bill not up
to the moment it's the latest chapter in
a pathetic response to the cost of
living crisis
[Applause]
where there should have been support
it's been tax rise after tax rise on
working people
the only country in the g7 to do so
during a cost of living crisis
the low growth
that led to the stagnation we see today
is the same reason wages have been
frozen for so long
over 12 years of tory government the
economy has grown far slower than when
labor was in power
and it's set to go even slower in coming
years
the slowest growing economy in the g7
next year as the director general of the
cbi said for a country that's used to
growth of two to two point five percent
the conservative record is simply not
good enough
[Applause]